[Musique]
non
monsieur van craeyenest comment ça se
présente cette foire du trône et bien
sûr le signe du beau temps je sache
qu'elle démarre toujours
traditionnellement le samedi de pâques
ici entre la nation et la porte de
vincennes et sans samedi de pâques et un
soleil resplendissant seront bien belle
journée
l'autre grand problème c'est le bruit
comment ça va ça touriste organisé cet
été voir nous avons fait le nécessaire
nous avons organisé nous mêmes une
police entre les industriels forains qui
se servent des amplificateurs pour
essayer de réduire le bruit au maximum
et j'espère que ça donnera en même temps
satisfaction aux riverains parce que
vous savez nous sommes une corporation
qui ont besoin de kerbeuz vannes se
dépense sans bruit a plu des cendriers
plus mais un peu malgré nos il faut dire
une chose qu'on ne sait pas en général
c'est que les fêtes foraines rapporte
beaucoup d'argent à aux caisses des
écoles des établissements que vous
traversez quels sont les établissements
existants nous avons dix billets vous
ici on nous avons le 11e 12e et 20e et
bien ces trois arrondissements se
partagent la somme pour l'heure pour le
fruit de la caisse des écoles de 82
millions que les parents versée pour un
mois et bien voilà une chose
intéressante est tout à votre honneur
alors maintenant je crois qu'il serait
bon puisque nous sommes à la foire du
trône de jeter un coup d'oeil sur une
parade brillante csn de votre franc
risque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien à la foire du trône cette année
il y à des nouveautés il ya par exemple
cette baraque dans laquelle on peut
gagner des poupées déguisé en
parachutistes qui est bien dans
l'actualité
et puis j league à terezin à la femme la
plus grosse du monde cher terezin à vous
peser combien desseins malsains qu'il
225 kg et vous venez d'amérique rien à
mary et vous avez travaillé à nice
l'année
l'idée avait emmené en est ce que vous
êtes content de travailler à la foire du
trône oui j'aime beaucoup le tarif et
j'ai l'impression que votre barak
commence à s'entourer d'une grosse foule
veiller que vous allez être très admiré
des temps mieux pas lire et parce qu'on
ne fait pas manu et réussit même celles
non je suis enfin j'espère voir beaucoup
de parisiens sourire charmant c'est ça
qui compte
dites moi cher président est ce que vous
êtes à izier ce que vous savez que la
foire du trône est aussi la foire au
pain d'épicés oui paraît qu'on donne des
cochons qui sont merveilleux ne donne
pas on les voit les 20 ha bon moment je
n'ai pas acheté des cochons fait pour
que au nom de vos amis de la vie et on
va dire ça chantait et moi
personnellement avant de quitter la
foire du trône c'est ce que je vais
faire je vais préparer cinq cochons au
nom d'un ami à moi et au nom de mes
directeurs à la place bien dans l'âme le
directeur
[Musique]